you're not running the marathon every
day I'm not going to be able to keep
working as I work systemize your
business so we worked it on on the
Saturday and then on the Sunday got my
first week's booking you need fast pound
and slow pounds if you own a property
you can try any scenario on it sometimes
I just think it's having the marbles to
do it
for coming down to my house
and it's just going to be great to pick
your brain about exactly what you've
done in property because you've
literally built houses from scratch
you've got service accommodation
properties that you've rent to rent
you've done biorefirmish refinance
combined with service accommodation on
properties so firstly congratulations on
your success why don't you just talk to
me a little bit about sort of how you
got into property and what was it that
got you started well me and Al have been
together for about 12 years and he's in
construction and has been doing building
Renovations and doing extensions Loft
conversions when we met and so he had
his own company and then we decided we
wanted to build our own house together
so we bought a plot of land and built
our own house once we finished we sold
that on and thought what should we do
with the money and decided to go into a
bit more into property I remember when
we first met we've got a lot of mutual
friends as well so Church mutual friends
and stuff like that but when we first
met we really got on Wow you told me
about your development that you've done
you're in construction and
um you know since then you've really
scaled and taken on more creative
strategies when did you decide you
wanted to do this as like not as a
part-time thing but go full time into
property and really make a proper career
of it I think it was last year really
was a bit of a turning point when we had
our fourth child and we were like we
need to do something and we need to get
attention we need to you know really up
our game to start building a future and
building our wealth parts and to be able
to carry on and give it over as a legacy
to our children yeah and what you do is
quite physically draining as well isn't
it yeah with the reason for getting into
property really is I won't be able to
sustain what I do for work forever yeah
because your body just don't let you do
that it's just like running the marathon
every day I'm not going to be able to
keep working as I work so if I can just
do it for us direct I get to see the
wealth that I'm creating rather than
creating for somebody else so once the
house is finished I can stand back and I
can go and visit that house I can do
whatever I want with with the houses if
I'm doing it for somebody else all the
time you don't get that gratification as
what you could get yeah I see a lot of
builders that have got the they know all
about property in terms of the bricks
and the mortar but they don't know how
to make money this is this is what we
wanted to come on the course it's like I
know how to build it I've got a plot of
land I can do all that but how am I
going to scale it yeah and that's why we
come straight to your course it's like
well yeah come down to yours it was it
was it's good it's an iron it's an
eye-opener for anyone that wants to get
going
like yourself I think for us it was kind
of like putting some of those jigsaw
pieces together yeah and like I would
say he's got the the skills I'm from
like a merchandising background so I'm
good with like finance and numbers and
things like that and so it was just
putting everything together and actually
going actually this is what you can do
with all your skill sets and so last
year when we joined the academy it was
just then about them building on that
knowledge and building like the one
thing that I always remember from one of
the courses I think it was the I can't
remember which one of one of the first
ones was that you've got a tool kit
everything's different so you've got
this you could do a lease option you
could do a service accommodation you
could do a vrr it's like you just need
to turn up to somewhere and go right
which one do I need but you need to
learn how to use every single totally
and that analogy clicks with you guys
yeah I say the same with golf yeah I say
if you say to a golfer what's the best
club what's your favorite Club well
there isn't of a builder what's your
favorite tool depends on what shot I'm
taking depends on what I'm so you know
in property it's the same you might
think oh there's there's a piece of land
like a builder house or there's an
existing house I can convert it I could
run it as a brr I could do it as a lease
option of service accommodation a HMO a
joint venture you've really got to have
your full toolkit and then you can
become like a property Problem Solver
talk me through your first rent to rent
and and how that came about so my first
French event came about last year
um I think we signed it in August last
year and it just came back from looking
on right move and things like that and
went with the agent and it was happened
to be an agent who understood what I was
trying to do yeah
I said right this is what I want and
he's like okay that shouldn't be a
problem and so he went away to the
um the landlord and was like okay she
wants to do this he came back and said
yep that's not a problem then I said
okay well I want no deposit and I want
six weeks rent free and he was like he's
not going to agree to that I'm like just
try it because it was an accident house
so he wasn't going to be renting it till
the end of September anyway and this was
August I was like just try it because he
he's not going to be renting it anyway
and he came back he was like yes he's
agreed it wow so my first rent to rent I
didn't put any money down
on it until my my I think I ended up
paying the first month and but that was
just to cover the very first month it
wasn't a deposit it was the first
month's rent wow and then you and then
you rented out what was a HMO or well
that was the initial thought I was like
okay this would be a great HMO it was um
it's three bedroom Terrace but it had a
like a separate two separate rooms
downstairs and then a kitchen Diner the
research that had done looked really
good for the numbers and then I put it
onto spare room things and think I just
wasn't getting anything back and
actually it was Al was like why don't
you try a service accommodation because
we started learning about things I
hadn't been on the service accommodation
course yet we were like okay let's try
it so we waxed it on on the Saturday and
then on the Sunday got my first week's
booking interesting that it wasn't
working as a HMO as well I think
sometimes it's the little bit of the
location that was a bit further away
from any Unis or anything that house was
it was in the city center to earn it
yeah and the other thing is but I think
it would work as a HMO or service
accommodation it's a perfect location
the only problem that I the feedback
that I got was I only had one bathroom
yeah and because we were still in a bit
of covered times
and back back last summer people were
still a little bit hesitant having one
bathroom but it goes back to having the
toolbox yeah because of the situation
and covered and it was a bit slow as a
HMO so bang you put it as accommodation
and instantly yeah and you've got to
know about service accommodation because
you've got all the complexities of oh
it's not it's not a five minute
operation just to set up you've got to
go and do the work you've got just a
case of putting it on booking.com and no
you've got to have cleaners you've got
to have the linen the key saves you've
got to have all the automated emails
take know how to take the payments get
registered on stripe it's a process it's
a business it is and because I hadn't
done any of the training as well so it
was quite um
a learning curve for me and I used to do
all the cleaning as well when we first
set up yeah
um so I did more I did about 50 covers
50 changeovers I think I I added off at
one point but I thought it was quite
good because I learned how I wanted it
how I wanted it set up and I knew that
when I did get my cleaners in place that
I could tell them this is how I want it
this is how long it's going to take you
yeah once you've put the you know
stopwatch to it yourself you know how
long job she takes yeah it's about
always replacing yourself isn't it do it
yourself to begin with but then quickly
replace yourself yes I managed to do
that replaced myself last year and no
actually it was beginning of this year I
was kind of forced to do it because I I
dislocated my kneecap so I couldn't
actually do anything for a while so I
was quickly on the phone trying to find
um that was that was God's way of saying
systemize your business yes if you don't
systemize it you'll break your ankle and
be forced to do it I was like Dan I'm
gonna go there every weekend and clean
this house it's not happening well we
ain't got time for that because is you
need to use your skills where they're
best suited and ours weren't cleaning
the house I was finding the houses doing
what we need to do what are the
advantages because it's interesting that
you went from you know building a house
and making a bunch of profit as a
developer to then do rent to rent
because rent to rent is seen as off by
many people a strategy that people do
when they've got no money they've got no
experience it's kind of a way of getting
your foot in the door to property but
you were already in property so what
made you choose rent to rent well I
quite like the whole service
accommodation thing I quite like the
hospitality side of it yeah and also we
wanted it for cash flow right so we
wanted the idea was that we start
replacing our cash cash flow with
something that was a little bit more
passive right and start freeing up our
time that makes a lot of sense because
you need as you always hear me say you
need fast pound and slow pound and
property development and even brr
it takes forever just to get the keys in
your hand and takes that takes three
three six months and then you've got the
refurb and the refinance so it's wealth
building it's slow but then having rent
to rent or deal so I need a bit of deal
sourcing as well it's fast yeah it's
quick pound and if you can have the
quick pound coming in now gives you time
to focus on them building your your
Empire and getting rich I think that's
what it is because we can use our part
of money when a good deal comes about
yeah so if there's if there's a good
deal well we're gonna go and get that
yeah we'll just go and get it whereas if
we spend all our money on one on loads
of like service accommodation properties
that we've invested into We're not gonna
have any money left to go and do the
development ones which is where you are
going to make the money and also with
rent to rent it's a really good way of
learning isn't it so if you're like your
service accommodation property that
first rent to rent that you got what
what sort of profit do you make from
that just over a thousand pounds cool a
month now we invested quite a bit of
money into it we invest about three
grand into it so we totally redecorated
it it's a nice home and made into a
really nice home bought more stuff for
it because it already had like beds and
wardros and things but you know
decorated made it into a really at least
you've got no deposit in free rent yeah
exactly so it took us a few months to
get that back and then we had a dip over
um Christmas because I had issues with
booking.com because again new trying to
work it out and work out how to use it
and um they'd taken it off the site so
then once we got all that sorted come
February we then started to make them
consistently see that thousand pounds a
month coming in yeah that's good and and
then with the experience from that you
then bought a house yeah so then at the
end of last year we bought a house
um to renovate and we were oven and
ironing all the way through the
renovation what we're going to do with
it and I don't I think you know what you
can like you know once you know property
you can do whatever you want with them
at the end of the day if you own a
property you can try any scenario on it
it doesn't matter what you do with it as
long as you can keep paying the mortgage
and you can keep paying the bills then
it doesn't matter whether you put it
service accommodation you rent it as a
buy to let HMO you can just change the
strategy of what you doing within that
property and I was very skeptical about
putting that one in Coventry the one
that we've read although Anna was very
confident yeah I went around that house
yeah and even before it had gone live
you were going it'll work that'd be fine
the house is mint it's really nice house
really nice homes what did you pay for
it we paid um one seven one 171 Grand
and how much of our refurb did it needed
like a structural problem
a an extension on the back did you uh
get a stamp Duty relief on it or was it
not that bad we're going through at the
moment you're going to record it back so
171 for the purchase yep company or
personal company so you bought it for
once everyone how much you have to spend
on it I know you did a lot of work
yourself you spent six days a lot of
that was trying to work and work so a
lot of the developments we do we just
ain't got time to be doing all the work
on them myself so we'll subcontract out
a lot and then I'll go after work and do
three or four hours if you want
something bad enough you'll work hard
for it yeah and it's as simple as that
and that's what I'll do I'll go to sites
or wherever I'm working at the time and
I'll then finish the day and go and do
three or four hours in the evenings and
some of those some of those nights at
the house it was 12 o'clock at night and
I'm in the roof insulating how much
profit did you make on that deal what
was the uplift so basically we got it
remortgaged at 290. so what's the profit
about 60 Grand that's not bad and it's
the fact that it's your own house it's
and it's it's really it's no like a new
home yeah so far and also as well when
you do a bar refurbatory Finance in my
opinion it's better than doing buy to
let because not only obviously can you
pull your money out of course but also
if you do a buy to let if you buy a
cheap house and rent it out you're gonna
have problems whereas when you do a
borrow Furniture Finance you're taking a
real Duff house and then you're making
it turn it into a mint house yep pulling
your money back out did you did you pull
out nearly all your money on that and
did you pretty much I think is about 15
grand there's about 15 grand in it so
you put you're basically buying a house
for 15 grand but now the house is mint
yeah it's got like a new roof and it's
got It's extended new carpets new
kitchen and you're not going to have
that the same maintenance issues that
you would if you just bought an older
house and we'll recoup that money in
about a year less than a year are you
renting it out of service accommodation
now yes how's it going that's what I
wanna know great go on talk to me about
that one July was really great month on
both the houses and I think we made
about just over two grand profit on the
drive wow what about all the builders
and cleaners that said it wouldn't work
yeah my brother
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's been and
it's been busy ever since yeah it's an
eye-opener isn't it what you can achieve
if you want to do things I mean that's a
really good time salary it didn't get
that every single month so we we hit
about you know between 12 and 1700 yeah
on that house what's the next one that
you've got then going on so we've got uh
Wolverhampton area Wolverhampton that's
my area that's a good it's only a couple
of months a couple of weeks down so what
are the what is it what are you doing
with it we're just going to do something
really similar to the drive to be honest
um we don't know what we're going to do
with the end strategy we're just going
to get it to a nice standard get it
evaluated and then reassess from there
talk to me about
um finding deals then where where
obviously you've got the skills to do
the build the hard bit about this
business is finding the deals and
negotiating the property because that's
what because a lot of Builders you know
they're really competent or or
accountants or property solicitors
they're Specialists so I've got builders
that work for me and they're brilliant
they know all about how to build from I
can build it out from scratch but they
haven't got the first clue about how to
get planning permission how to find a
site how to negotiate how to structure a
joint venture nothing how to work out
the end value nothing sometimes I just
think it's having the marbles to do it I
really do I just think it's having the
marbles to go out there and do it and
that's that's the key isn't it like
what's the worst can happen if you lose
a little bit of money you make money and
with property though it's not I don't
want to sound flippant but it's not that
risky because if you buy if you buy
something and it doesn't work well you
property goes up in value over time
you've got to play the long game and if
you're not prepared to play the long
game then you can make good money on it
like we're making good money on the
service accommodation and that could be
good for somebody that wants to get out
of the Rat Race and things like that and
have their own independence it's going
to be really good and I'd recommend it
because it gives you that freedom but
it's not a five minute fix to solve say
like you you're in your job and you
don't like your job it's not that five
minute fix it's long-term Investments
long-term gain and that's that's why a
lot you're saying now what makes us find
the right deal wow how does anybody know
what the right deal is you've just got
to go for it unless you've got
hundreds of people that you can phone up
and say what's Parliament doing tomorrow
what's going to happen with the markets
what's going to you just gotta keep
going haven't you I think that and no
one really knows 100 anyway I mean I've
made predictions oh well very rarely
have actually been wrong I'm usually
pretty right but the truth is like no
one could have ever respected covert no
one no and then suddenly when covered
came over half a million property sales
were paused Airbnb booking.com you
weren't allowed to advertise on there
yeah how can you predict that so I think
you've got to get educated as best you
can and then you've got to bite the
bullet and just go for it haven't you
when you've got that education I think
actually the decisions that you're
making aren't going to be that bad do
you know what I mean it's not like
you're coming from being under educated
so where do you get your deals from are
they from agents are they from deal
sources the first house that I did when
I was 23 24 that was our we were so
called Forever home but we've got too
big we have too many children so we had
to move from there and that was from
from an auction yeah and we met the
vendor on site we went to go and see him
he didn't want to sell the land to us we
were going to give him 150 000 for it
and then went to auction and we thought
oh actually you know we turned up late
to the auction yeah it was meant to be
sometimes you know things are meant to
be yeah you know expecting it to go for
some really high figure we just wanted
to see what would happen we were we were
really young then we were just like
naive let's go and have a look let's
just go and have a look that was 10
years ago that was yeah and then it
didn't sell so we were like perfect
quick quick so I got on the phone to my
dad who's been like our angel investor
Dad can we have that money please can we
borrow that money and we basically made
them lock the the um doors to the room
yeah they couldn't they couldn't let
anything because everyone else was still
out there on the phone trying to sort
themselves I was like no no we're good
to go can we do a deal now we're going
now we're doing it now we've got a
really good bargain on it and then the
second one was was the flat that was at
the same time as the the other land
wasn't it yeah so we bought we then went
to an um 2019 we went to another auction
and bought a flat and a piece of land at
the same time yeah the auctioneers loved
us yeah they did auction is is is really
good you know we buy a lot of auctions
as well but talking about the risk in
property if you don't know what you're
doing I would probably say be careful
with an auction because if you don't
know how to read a legal pack we can't
the kind of the second time we didn't
read the legal pack which is yeah we
didn't and the flat that that's the
prime example really of just um rushing
in and we didn't read the legal package
definitely not worth doing that you do
need to do your paper oh mate I I read
sometimes when I'm in legal packs before
I bid it's scary what it says they do
over complicate things they really do if
you was to speak to somebody about what
it actually says it's it's like what if
you just why don't you just say it in
English straightforward well often spend
a day I'll pay a solicit their hourly
rate 700 quid an hour and I'll say I
want to spend 10 hours with you and I'll
just pick their brain for 10 hours
that's how I learn but yeah the flap
that we bought that wasn't wasn't the
best and that was that was like that's
why you need to do your homework yeah it
was paying I think we were making like I
don't know 20 quid of swing a month from
it was it no well we owned that outright
so we were making like 400 pounds a
month on it have you done any deal
selling and I was badgering you about
that have you done any yeah so we've
doubled at it and not been that
successful how many deals have you sold
so yes
um to be honest we've only really
actually tried to but you've been doing
other stuff you needed rent to rent
you've been doing brr service
accommodation you've got four kids I
think we're using most of our skill set
in the building side of it like with the
developments and the bras we're using
that skill set because we we you know
sometimes we know that don't we what's
the end goal like over the next sort of
five years where do you plan on taking
the property business we don't want to
be working for anyone else yeah we want
because we want people we both still
work
um for other people and so we want to be
working
for ourselves full time and I think
that's a realistic goal and that I want
that before five years I want that like
and how much money do you need to be
making to the point whereby you you feel
like you can now quit work and you can
quit between the two of you about 10
grand yeah and that's another thing as
well because I know I said to you I
really want to interview because you're
making thousands of pounds a month
you've made a lot of money in property
and you were like well we're not quite
out of our jobs yet though but I was
thinking well let's do a part two
because if right now you know you're
making thousands of pounds a month
you've got all these deals going on
um it's incredible it's it's it's
winners Wednesday were they
um and then we can do we can do a
follow-up in a year or two I mean how
much did you make on that development
that you did the first one we made over
300 000. that's incredible yeah it was
over a long period and it was a lot it
was a long period but it was our our
house it was our family home yeah there
was never an intention to stay there
forever property is a vehicle and for
some people they're working in JD Sports
making 1500 quid a month and and I just
want to get one or two rent to rent and
get out and to them making two grand a
month passive income is Financial
Freedom yeah for you guys it's not no no
you want you want 10 plus and you've got
different goals and property can take
you wherever you want to go if people
want to get in touch what's the best way
for people to reach out best on my
Instagram at Hannah J Bowden thanks once
again for coming down no problem thank
you thank you
thank you
[Music]